the function f of X is equal to 6x
squared plus 18x plus 12 over x squared
minus 4 is not defined at X is equal to
positive or negative 2 and we see that Y
that is if X is equal to positive or
negative 2 then x squared is going to be
equal to positive 4 and 4 minus 4 is 0
and then we're going to have a 0 in the
denominator and that's not defined we
don't know what happens when you divide
or we've never defined what happens when
you divide by 0 so they say what value
should be assigned to F of negative 2 to
make f of X continuous at that point so
to think about that let's try to
actually simplify f of X so f of X I'll
just rewrite it is equal to actually let
me just start simplifying right from the
get-go so in the numerator I can factor
out a 6 out of every one of those terms
so it's 6 times x squared plus 3x plus 2
over and the denominator this is a
difference of squares this is X plus 2
times X minus 2 and then we can factor
this expression up here so this is going
to be equal to 6 times let me do it in a
different color so we think of two
numbers that if I take their product I
get two if I take their sum I get three
the most obvious one is two and one so
this is 6 times X plus 2 times X plus
one when you take the product there
you'll get x squared plus 3x plus 2 and
then all of that all of that over X plus
2 times X minus 2
now if we know that X does not equal
negative 2 then we can divide both the
numerator and the denominator by X plus
2 the reason why I'm making that
constraint is that if X were to be equal
to negative 2 that X plus 2 is going to
be equal to 0 and you won't be able to
do that you can't we don't know what it
means to divide something by 0 so we
could say that this is going to be equal
to so if we we can divide the numerator
and the denominator by X plus 2 but we
have to assume that X is not equal to
negative 2 so this is equal to 6 6 times
so we're going to have
we're going to divide by X plus 2 in the
numerator X plus 2 in the denominator so
it's going to be 6 times X plus 1 X plus
1 over X minus 2 over X minus 2 and we
have to put the constraint here because
now we've changed it now this expression
over here is actually defined at x
equals negative 2 but in order to be
equivalent to the original function we
have to we have to constrain it so we
will say 4 for X not equal not equal to
negative 2 and it's also obvious that X
can't be equal to 2 here this one also
isn't defined at positive 2 because
you're dividing by 0 so you could say
for X does not equal to positive or
negative 2 if you want to make it very
explicit but they asked us what can we
assign F of negative 2 to make the
function continuous at the point well
the function is completely equivalent to
this to this expression except that the
function is not defined at x equals
negative 2 so that's why we have to put
that constraint here if we wanted this
if we wanted this to be the same thing
as our original function but if we want
if we wanted to re-engineer the function
so it is continuous at that point well
then we just have to set f of X equal to
whatever this expression would have been
when X is equal to negative 2 so let's
think about that let's think about that
so 6 6 times negative 2 plus 1 over
negative 2 minus minus 2 is equal to
this is 6 times negative 1 so it's
negative 6 over negative 4 which is
equal to 3 halves so if we redefine f of
X if we say if we say f of X is equal to
f of X is equal to 6x squared plus 18x
plus 12 over x squared minus 4 4 for X
not equal positive or negative 2 and
it's equal to 3 halves
4
x equals negative two now this function
is going to be the exact same thing as
this right over here this f of X this
new one this new definition this
extended definition of our original one
is now equivalent to this expression is
equal to six times X plus one over X
minus 2 but just to answer the question
what value should be assigned to F of
negative two to make f of X continuous
at that point well f of X should be or F
of negative two should be three halves